und jetzt beginnt die challenge wir
schlagen uns im deathmatch mit nur drei
kisten schaffen wir es mir runter zu
gewinnen
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
videospiel heute wieder jump liegt die
street geht weiter und wir haben eine
neue zuschauer durch die stammt von
leukämie und er sagt spiel nochmal die
alle guten dinge sind drei challenge
dass insgesamt drei kistner einsammeln
einen easy modus eine in den normalmodus
eilen den harten beats natürlich das den
inhalt der kiste abchecken bevor die
luft ist viel glück okay leute tv ein
problem wenn doch mal direkt mal eine
change aus also das prinzip ist es gibt
ja zehn module und aus jeder
schwierigkeit klasse darf man sich genau
eine kiste mitnehmen bereit neviges
morgen wenn ich gebe nicht die stoff
desto
ich bin falls ihr das seht oder merck
allein vom momentan bisschen
verschnaufen ich habe da tatsächlich
mein dozentin der uni angesteckt finden
wir die gut das ist findet das für musik
ist ziemlich gut dass die dinger mit
sehr schön
ok jetzt schnell schnell weiter denn die
anderen haben natürlich nicht unsere
probleme in kisten
was ich sagen wollte ist dass ich am
dienstag durch nehmen dass gerade am
mittwochabend auf der uni war und mein
dozent auch schon schuppen hatte also
der quali drohen ihn lehrer der auf
jeden fall auflaufen hatte und die ganze
zeit herum lief so auch um mich herum
tourende wie leute hätte ich einen raum
laufen wenn sie irgendwas erzählen
an der uni ist die idee die dozenten und
da hat er mich eiskalt angesteckt jetzt
bin ich krank musste gestern schon den
livestream absagen am mittwoch und ja
heute schon verschluckt in der aufnahme
das hält es natürlich nicht davon ab
hier trotzdem zu versuchen eine schöne
runde hinzulegen
soweit und damit wir bei den normen
modulen here & now heißt wir dürfen
ober- als er richtig klappt mit der
leiter november heißt wir dürfen jetzt
wieder unsere zweite kiste anpeilen wir
versuchen so weit ich ist mir zu nehmen
wollen eine sache wohl auch nochmal
ansprechen leute und zwar finde ich dass
ich in meinen videos zu nett bin zu nett
bin ich drück mich zu freundlich
ausfindig ich würde müsste in meinen
videos viel mehr fluchen einfach oder
mit meine videos möglichst zu 100
prozent genauso sind wie auch im alltag
rede dass person mein persönlicher
wunsch nötig ist
dies kann aber nicht ich kann man ja mal
was aus der perspektive eines youtube
essentiell so nämlich dass man
runterfällt verdammt ich wollte sagen
dass man irgendwie sämtlichen
sprachgebrauch so wissen verändert also
wir sagen dass man verändert wie man
redet wenn man aufnimmt
das ist ein gewissen punkt ganz normal
glaube ich glaube niemand ist vor der
kamera so wie er ist wenn die kamera weg
ist zimmerleute die erzählt vor release
protokoll genau hinter der kamera aber
vor der kamera es glaube ich jeder ein
bisschen aufgedreht oder so da zeigt
andere seiten von sich bei mir war aber
die sache als ich finde dass ich zu zu
brav und
kinder spielen in meiner auch im echten
leben bin ich ketten hose lockt
natürlich schon mal aber dass man nicht
mehr im echten leben bin ich deutlich ja
wieso man sagen der war als in meinen
videos heißt als ich benutze mehr
schimpfwörter und eine ganz andere
sprache
und ich möchte versuchen so ein bisschen
meine sprache die ich im alltag
sprechern das anzupassen was sie eine
video spreche um die videos noch
authentischer zu machen und das einfach
mehr so weg zu haben
was mir auch durchaus sehr wichtig ist
so zack bumm
ich muss am laufenden band meiner nase
putzigkeit das alles raus für euch aber
what the hell also die kiste gerade eben
war nicht spannend mal gucken dies mit
der kiste in dem module aussieht wo
wissen beim modul 7
hab ich da eine kiste versteckt
zwischendurch ich schön könnte es eine
enorme kiste gehabt okay er hat dann
haben wir bisher schon zwei und es folgt
jetzt in dem modul die dritte was heißt
wir müssen eigentlich den inhalt dieser
kiste mit nehmen deswegen hoffe ich dass
er gut ist
bitte bitte bitte bitte brauchen was das
wir noch nicht haben und meist ein
schwert und die shampoos sind auch nicht
schlecht sehr gut okay damit hat man so
zweite kiste geblutet mäßig sieht gerade
ein bisschen dünn aus bei uns aber dafür
jump mäßig gar nicht schlecht wir sind
trotz unserer challenge auf platz eins
gerade erst recht ganz neues ist und der
mitgenommenen checkpoint ich rede über
den blog darüber aber der jackpot wurde
ausgelöst sehr leid so jetzt müssen uns
nur noch überlegen welche der drei hat
kisten nehmen wir mit so was ist hier
drin ergänzt ich würde fast sagen nee
ich würde fast sagen nein wird fast
sagen die als lohnt sich für broich noch
was anderes und richtung bau oder so
oder eine kiste mit einer change
ex-playmate changes playtainment
bauleute können wir die runde ohne
leggins spielen
wisst ihr was ich pokere ich pokere ich
sag das in der letzten kiste um kiste 10
die natürlich auch erst mal erreichen
müssen aber ich sage dass eine kiste 10
das ultimative op gucken drin ist
ich verlasse mich aber darauf dass in
kisten besseres equipment kisten 8 und 9
ist die wir gerade eben wir schon liegen
gelassen haben und drückt einfach mal
die daumen
ich habe davon nur am schnecke ist also
ein stein schwert und ein bisschen food
dann haben wir richtig gelitten können
die die roots holen in dem finnischen
aber was er dann okay und dir gut sind
auch nicht versprochen dafür muss man
auch erst mal dieses modell schaffen
es sah alles klar
und jetzt haben wir das bruder auch okay
und unsere letzte kiste leute bitte
bitte bitte irgendwas gutes neil riches
unter ihren leggins dann bin ich
zufrieden dann bin ich mehr als
zufrieden
und okay leute glück gehabt wir haben
nun mal jetzt bekommen wir müssen das
ding bieten hier den eisernen reisende
mit wo ich schon schön habt wisst ihr
was ist jetzt egal
drei kisten ganz ordentlich ist mir
fehlt natürlich die angel mir fehlen im
deathmatch dann pfeil und bogen ehrlich
gesagt aber dafür können uns jetzt schon
die diaby zählen am ende sagt sagt sagt
soziales kuriosen anziehen und jetzt
beginnt die challenge geschlagen wird im
bett match mit nur drei kisten da ist
unser erster erkannt sagt attac wir
können es hat die gegner nicht wegrollen
wir müssen jetzt einfach alles nur mit
smart machen
ich würde sagen wir dürfen aber die
kisten gelobten okay dass er vor gar
nichts dann aber gerade die runde
verloren das ist glaube ich so eine
leere kiste und wenn jemand die runde
verlässt es kommt mir alles klar haben
wir den drei mal getroffen
noch ein paar mal ein zwei mal noch dann
bist du fertig mein freund zac got the
prospect of the watchtower es tut weh
the words in münster wie kann ich mich
nicht mehr verstecken und dieser weg ist
schön das ist okay wir sind noch nicht
gestorben haben uns aber noch kein
equipment hier schnappen können oder
runde gegen dessen gegner des gegner ok
drauf drauf hat er sein schwert geklappt
da ist okay es dann erst dann glaube ich
habe ich ihn geholt und mal gucken was
in der kiste ist ihr habt nice nice nice
wären staffeln feuerzeug rausbekommen
für die angler hat sich mehr gereicht
zum 10 er hat eine eigene der kann uns
weg wurden kann die besseren kurs geben
aber vielleicht habe ich jetzt so weit
schon erwischt haben wir als ok freut
mich dass das das mit dass mit dass mit
das mit sehr gut froh dass unsere das
nächste gekracht so könnt ihr die runde
vielleicht clean spielen 06 das wäre ja
und wir haben weggeholt sehr schön und
jetzt machen wir mal ganz flugs würde
ich sagen kleines fns was diese map
ziemlich op ist weil ich ehrlich gesagt
keine ahnung habe wo ihr wasser sein
soll
so jetzt kann er wieder an der zeit wenn
die rutschen yusen air nicht im nahkampf
user wie ich gerade geleistet haben wir
auch weg läuft de ist läuft guckt es
läuft darum ist er ja schon mal abstand
sagte abstand wichtigste und coffee
table jetzt wieder ans werk und nice wo
unser fns gibt uns ein bisschen raum zum
atmen da kommt ja nicht so gegner boxen
könnte man es rein
als ob das nicht sein ernst das ist
nicht ein verdammter ernst gerade das
ist nicht dein verdammt ernst gerade und
ich spotify really really really als
arbeiter das gibt es nicht da hat er uns
mit dieser kleinen cleaner fraktion voll
die kleine runde versaut dafür wollen
wir jetzt erklären dann ist er für mich
sehr schön sagt und ob er noch ein eisen
gewesen wir hätten uns theoretisch
einfach in eisenstadt machen können mist
schaffen wir es mit nur drei kisten die
runde zu gewinnen
es wird sich jetzt zeigen
dass unser gegner leisten kann falls sie
kein feuer
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] se war ach du scheiße
failed
das nährt sich die runde gewöhnlicher
soweit kunst doch so weit kommt auf den
falschen weg hier
so kämpfte hier da ist der ist jedoch
dass zack zack jetzt brennt nämlich
jetzt so muss sein
jetzt ständig zu sagt meissner wollen
dann haben wir nämlich auch sie also
leute auch mit drei kisten kann man die
runde gewinnen schöne kleine challenge
von lol tv ich hoffe dass wieder hatte
ich auch gefallen ich habe mich jetzt
trotz krankheit mal wo ich hin gesetzt
wir sind von nächsten video wieder wie
immer challenge ideen auch gerne mal für
andere spielmodi ich bin jetzt bereit
obwohl ich das anders als job league zu
spielen könnte auch in die kommentare
schreiben
und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten
video bis dann